hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel and in this
video
i'm going to be answering all of your
property investment
questions i've been investing in
properties now for 12
years i've done over 300 property deals
so i know i thing or two
about securing a good deal so do me a
favor
comment below all of your property
investment questions and i'm going to do
my best
to answer your questions however if you
want to be successful in property
the thing that you need to do to start
with the very first move is you need to
like this video so like the video
also subscribe to the channel because
how devastating would it be
if you ask a really good question and
then i answer your question on next
week's sunday q a
but you haven't subscribed and turn the
notification bell on
so you don't even know that the video
exists that'll be devastating i know so
smash this like button also subscribe
and turn the notification bell on
let's see what questions we've had of
last week and as i'm answering questions
you might have an offshoot question that
you might think oh actually what about
just comment it below like crazy i'm
going to be answering
my very best next week ahmed campino
how are you preparing your property
business
for 2021 great question so 2021 is
really really close
how am i preparing um well listen i
don't think it makes massive difference
that we're about to go into a new year
like i i don't really do like new year's
revolutions and everything's gonna be
different like i've kind of been winning
month after month after month for the
last decade so i'm not gonna do anything
majorly different what i will say though
is moving into 2021
tenants tenants rights are
more than they've ever been i mean right
now you can't evict a tenant up until
march 31st
if they're not paying rent so i guess
what i'm doing right now is
how i'm preparing for the new year can i
see your question whenever we're putting
a tenant into one of our properties
we're making sure that there are good
tournaments you know we're credit
checking them we're making we're
having references off them it's never
been true i've said this before but
i always say the only thing worse than
no tenant
is a bad tenant that's never been truer
as we move into 2021 so if you've got
a lot of properties or any properties at
all my advice to you would be to prepare
is to prepare the tenants make sure
they're good tenants i'm i'm renting a
lot of my properties to
companies housing associations um
getting good tenants in short stay let
so i've got service accommodation
where they don't have any tenants rights
so i think i'd probably say the best way
i'm preparing is by preparing my
properties for the right tenants
so that it's geared with the times i
hope that helps
let me know if it does ahmed campino all
right meshack i have 50
000 pounds but don't want to put it all
into one
property what does it mean to recycle
your money
in property great question and it sounds
like if you've got 50 000 pounds and
you're about to buy a property
you're absolutely right it sounds greedy
you know people say
you can't have your cake and eat it too
what's the point of having a cake if you
can't eat it
and if you've got 50 000 pounds i agree
with you meshach
you don't want to put it into a property
and then just wait
so my advice would be to
recycle it but the whole question was
what does that mean what that means
is that you're going to put okay if
you've got 50 grand i
might do a whole separate video about
this because it's quite a big topic but
if you've got 50 grand
you could just buy a house for 200 grand
and then just wait for it to go up or
you could find a really run-down house
for a hundred thousand pounds
that would be worth two hundred thousand
pounds if it was nice
you put down your 50 grand but then you
borrow the other 50 grand from a
bridging company
and you buy it cash you then borrow more
money on a bridging loan
to refurb the properties maybe spend 50
grand refurbing it
so but then you refinance up to its new
value of 200
000 pounds and you're going to get a 75
loan to value
and with that money you're going to pay
off all of the bridging finance company
and pay yourself back
you get your 50 grand back so you're
going to use that 50 grand again and
again and again as many times as you can
i hope that helps it's a big question
it's a big topic
um we do run training programs on this
i'll put
some some in the description of the
video i'll put some links where you can
join samuel 365 you can do the crash
course the crash course is free by the
way
um but be careful don't rush to spend
that 50 grand
you want to buy the right property
that's my biggest advice good luck
meshach
sheila cooper 987 i'm about to complete
on my first hmo thanks to your hmo
bootcamp which was amazing by the way ah
thank you sheila i appreciate you
on the course you spend a lot of time
teaching how to find and manage a tenant
yourself
but i was planning on using a hmm
management company to do this what is
best great question so firstly
congratulations the fact that you've got
html about to complete
i'm going to see you on winners on a
wednesday real soon no doubt in terms of
managing yourself managing getting a
hmn management company to do it you know
about that we talk about that on the hmo
bootcamp as well
and then there's self-managing it it
depends on how much time you've got
available
i mean i would all the reason on the hmi
boot camp
i teach you how to manage it yourself is
because personally if you can
i advise doing it first yourself so you
know exactly what needs to be done
because then you've done it you found
the tenants you've put the adverts up
you know the contracts you do it
yourself to begin with and then once
you've got your first property up and
running and you found the tenants and
you've got it systemized
then take on a hmm management company
then they won't be able to pull the wall
over your eyes
i'm struggling to find the tenant well
hold on i found tenants three months ago
when i was doing it
oh this is i did it so
it helps if you do it the experience
that you'll get
the money that you'll save then
outsource it
if you can now listen if you just
haven't got the time sheila
and you'd like look i can't i live
really far away then fine
choose well choose a html management
company
choose them well get make sure they're
recommended again on the program you
should have our recommended
suppliers and stuff like that um and you
should pay between 10 and 15
of the rent um but i would really do it
yourself to begin with
if you can surely i hope that helps give
us a call anytime
shout us out reach out to us or comment
below on the video whatever's best
thank you so much guys if you enjoyed
the video smash the like button that'd
really help
all right jack along mere says how do
you propose i go about finding a
property that will appreciate
in value um jack if you want to find a
problem that's going to go up in value
firstly
no one's got a crystal ball okay i can't
i can't say
that property is going to go up in
capital appreciation over the next few
years because we do
not know some little pieces of advice
though is firstly
don't wait for the property to go up in
value force the value up by fixing
something to the property that's the
biggest
advice i can give you for example if the
property's not got
central heating in it then you're
probably gonna have to buy it cheap
and then by fixing that problem and
putting heating in the property you're
gonna probably push the value up
so in terms of long-term capital
appreciation
then find an area that's trending you
want you want to catch on what most
people do is they're too late they miss
the trend
and and there's trends in just about
every you know in music
in business at schools pokemon cards i
remember when they were trending and
they became big
in property you want to be the same you
want to be thinking what's
just beginning to peak you know what
what's tre
about to go big what most people do they
jump on the trend when it's too late
oh wow you know property prices have
gone up by
50 in the last three years is it crazy
and everyone starts buying but they get
on too late and then it dips
what you want to do is you want to find
an area that's been really stagnant for
a long time
but you know that there's regeneration
happening and you can find this on the
council websites
there's regeneration happening there's
investors coming in
properties have bottomed out and they're
just beginning to
and then you buy so no one knows for
sure what's gonna happen in the future
also remember capital appreciation
doesn't pay the bills rent
does so you want to always make sure
that every property you've got is cash
flowing
monthly uh it's positive cash flow each
month really really important so there's
some tips for you i hope that helps
let's see what else we got
raz van gabriel if you set up a limited
company and buy a house through that
limited company
are you allowed to rent a room out to
yourself yes you are
you're allowed to rent the whole house
out to yourself if you want
um all right h hi samuel thanks for your
video your theories apply to outside of
uk
as well as for us foreigner to invest
into the uk thanks
um yeah 100
listen h whether you're investing in the
uk
or outside of the uk whether you're
investing in the uk from overseas
or from in the uk like the strategies
are pretty much the same
my buy refurbished refinance rent
strategy that i teach
and i do and i've been teaching for
years people are taking that in america
and doing that strategy when rent to
rent
when you rent a property and rent it out
on
airbnb this is a global thing
yeah i'm doing it in the uk and i'm
teaching in the uk hmos
and if you want to do this the stuff in
the uk from overseas that's okay you
just need to have a good power team
now listen i'm not saying every single
thing i say applies
internationally but the vast majority of
it and the principles behind it
do hope that helps all out
i'm looking for somebody to joint
venture with discuss possible property
investments
not exactly the typical way to find a
partner by posting a youtube comment but
if anyone would like to have a chat
please get in touch all out cool
um yeah i guess that's not really a
question that's more you're kind of
putting yourself out there which
which is great uh if you are asking
though if you're kind of trying to get
my advice on how to
get a joint venture partner and how to
put yourself out there i think my
biggest advice for you
all out um would be to get into online
communities
where you can add some value you know i
mean there's nothing wrong with your
post
at all you know good for you i hope you
find some joint ventures but
unlikely when you put yourself out there
like that and say hey i'm looking for a
joint venture partner
from an anonymous account like we don't
know who you are
it's unlikely that someone's going to be
like yeah let's do business
because they don't know you they don't
trust you they don't
like you not because you're unlikable or
untrustworthy or
because they just don't know who you are
so you want to build relationships with
people and the best way to do that is by
on on social media find people
commenting and then come and interact
and add value to them and help them and
always be kind as well
um you know so good luck with what
you're doing and
uh i wish you all the best okay so jonas
holika hi sam you're just wondering what
did you do in school like what gcse and
did you go to college or sixth form
thank you
um not really no i didn't do too well in
school i left school at 16 years old i
had a
i think i had three gtses i got a couple
b's
and then a d i did okay not really that
great
i didn't go to sixth form i didn't go to
college i just started working straight
away from my dad
i didn't particularly like working for
my dad i didn't want to be in the rat
race i didn't want to be a slave to
anybody
and that was when i became a property
entrepreneur age 17 years old
and became financially free by age 21. i
did actually go
back to college i round about when i was
about 20
i went to bible college to study
theology but that was more from a
personal
perspective rather than trying to get
grades or trying to you know when i went
to bible college
i was already pretty much financially
free so that's kind of like my
background
so wherever you're at you can do it if
you if you're academic if you're not
academic
learn the skills you can succeed okay
one or two more questions
bob millian says when's the eviction
finishing
and what is the prize also how do i
apply when's it finishing i don't know
what you exactly mean by
that by that we have now finished all of
the filming for the eviction
it is going to be coming out we're going
to be broadcasting it on
boxing day okay which is real real soon
now
26th of december is coming out it's
going to be pretty epic and i really
hope that you enjoy it
it was a very very very hard long slog
with a lot of work
but the guys i'm not going to tell you
too much because i'll spoil it but check
it out put it in your diary it's 26th of
december when you say when does it
finish uh we finished filming now um
i mean we're going to put it out
back-to-back so episode 1 is 26
episode 27 episode 3 28 like bang bang
bang
you're gonna love the eviction like i
could i'll probably do a whole video at
some point maybe after it broadcasts
um talking about the experience that
happened but honestly
it was crazy if anyone doesn't know the
eviction is when i take 10 people and
set them challenges
and evict people every week and then the
winner gets uh
and then you actually ask what's the
price the prize is
i move into their house and help them
become financially free
which will change their financial future
for the rest of their lives
so it's a pretty big prize how do you
apply
well we've done it now so you can't
apply for 2020 if we do it again in the
future
check out for social media alert
subscribe to the channel and i always do
give lots of notice so
thanks bob good luck okay last question
miss savannah how much tax you have to
pay when deal sourcing and how does it
work um wait listen when you're making
money
you usually have to pay tax on that
money if you're deal sourcing
you're being a property entrepreneur so
set up a limited company the first 11
000 pound approximately you won't pay
any tax on that's profit not turnover
so you're going to be claiming expenses
back any courses that you do
travel food taking clients out for
dinners you're gonna be claiming back
network events claiming about to keep
your profit as small as possible
and you only pay tax on profit after
around eleven thousand pounds but don't
worry about that
um tyrone saxton tyrone sacks
he says um i think he's probably right
actually he says just find deals and
people will buy
it's like asking who do we pay tax at a
car boot sale just sell the stock
yeah tyrone has got a point on this
actually tyrone is is probably the most
the most vocal person on on on youtube
so we appreciate you tyrone
keep it kind though brother i appreciate
you but keep it kind bro
but yeah like you know just make money
focus on making money if you if you
focus on saving tax but you're not
making money you're letting the tail wag
the dog
you don't want the tail to rag the dog
you want to make money focus on money
making activities
then worry about paying tax as little
taxes you can ethically
and morally on that money that you make
so i hope that helps guys i really wish
you all the very best in your property
journeys as
entrepreneurs as investors and it's a
real honor to be able to help you
whether that be for free on youtube
on the courses at the events i hope to
see you in person hope to see the
property investors crash course
so if you have a question comment below
i'll see you real soon
don't forget to subscribe thanks so much
for watching see you next time
you